[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK PETRUZZI: Thank you
all for coming today.
And as you might guess
from hearing my background
as a personal
consumer, I certainly
spend a lot of my time trying
to practice what I preach
and reducing my footprint and
shopping with the environment
and human health more in mind.
Just as an example, my
two boys have recently
become very, very interested
in how their hair looks
and how they smell.
And so, of course,
that means dad
has to help them shop to
find personal care products
that I'm comfortable
with them putting
on their person, for
whatever purposes
in middle school and elementary
school that they're now being
so interested in having that.
And it takes a
little longer to shop
with dad, because I
tend to read more labels
and look for more
ecolabels because
of what I do for a living.
But finding more
sustainable products
is not always that easy.
Unlike when you
go to a restaurant
and you see the letter grade
right there very clearly
telling you the sanitation
rating for that restaurant.
Or if you're buying an
electrical appliance
of some sort where you can
go to the end of the plug
and look for the
little hologram sticker
to tell you that
that's been certified
for electrical safety, sometimes
it takes a little bit of work.
And how do you know
if something really
is as green as it's claiming
it is or as you want it to be?
So, one of the ways that we do
that in other areas of our life
is by asking trusted
third parties.
Particularly when we're
shopping with our values
or spending a lot of
money on something.
So, cars-- buying a car is a
good example-- buying a diamond
engagement ring is another
one, and buying a house.
So if you're buying a
diamond engagement ring,
you're spending a couple of
months' salary on something.
The jeweler says this
is a great stone,
but you want that third party
certificate that tells you it's
the right cut,
carat, clarity, and--
what's the other one--
I forget the fourth C.
It's been a while since I
bought my engagement ring.
But same thing when
you buy a house.
The bank is going to want to
do an independent appraisal
to make sure it's
worth what they
think it's worth with their
third party appraiser.
You're probably going
to want to get a home
inspection from a third party.
Because the seller says
it's a great house.
We've never had any problems.
But occasionally you
do find some things.
And then our 2005
minivan recently
died, so we had the lovely
experience of buying
a new used car for our family.
And nobody really loves
to go car shopping.
So luckily, you can use
a trusted third party.
You can buy a
certified pre-owned
which has gone through
an extensive checklist
to give you that comfort.
If you're buying something
out of the classifieds,
maybe you bring your Uncle Frank
who's really good with cars
or you bring your mechanic--
a trusted third party--
to make sure the car really
is what you think it is.
Because you're spending
a lot of money.
So this is something that
we're very used to doing.
But what about the smaller
purchases or purchases
now where we're shopping
with our values for health
or environmental reasons?
And that's where third
party ecolabels can help.
So today we're going
to talk a little bit
about a network of ecolabels
from all around the world that
can really help you identify
what "green" really means.
And about a party that
we're having in just a few
short weeks here to celebrate
the first annual World Ecolabel
Day.
Now, I can't guarantee
that your boss is
going to give you that
day off, but please
feel free to advocate for that.
It's the first one, so there's
no historical precedent.
But we're really celebrating
the power of certified green
products to build that trust
with consumers who want to shop
and look for more
sustainable products,
the power of third party
ecolabels to protect against
greenwashing or false green
claims-- which unfortunately,
there's still a
lot of out there--
and the power to provide
superior environmental
performance.
And we'll talk about all of
these as we go through today
But the Global Ecolabelling
Network is that organization.
And they've been
linking consumers
to a world of environmentally
preferable products
now for a quarter of a century.
And that's very
exciting, and I've
been privileged to
be a part of that.
So each one of these
little red pins
is one of the programs
that's a member of the Global
Ecolabelling Network.
And currently there
are 27 ecolabels
from all around the
world representing nearly
60 countries and territories.
And new programs are joining
all the time, which is exciting.
As new programs
emerge, we want to make
sure that they're among the
brotherhood of credible ones
and not necessarily
the fluffy ones.
So these members are all
third party sustainability
certifications that award
their seal of approval
only after their rigorous
environmental standards have
been met.
That's the only way you can
get these seals of approval.
So these certification labels--
or ecolabels, for short--
are based collectively on
about 1,500 different standards
that these 27 programs
have developed
for a wide range of product
and service categories.
And they can be found on
over 600,000 products sold
all over the world.
This idea, however,
of certifying products
that meet some sort of a
higher environmental standard
is not a new one.
The Blue Angel Program
in Germany, for example,
is the oldest member of the
Global Ecolabelling Network,
and they've been doing
this for over 40 years.
So this idea has been
around for a while.
We're just continuing
to educate folks
on which are the good
guys that you can trust.
The European Union ecolabel,
the official certification
for the EU members, sometimes
called the EU flower
because of the look.
There's nearly
4,000 companies that
have received certifications
from the China Environmental
Labeling Program for their
products and services.
And the two US-based members
of GEN, Ecologo and Green Seal,
are specified in the procurement
guidelines of more than half
of the 50 US states for
things like cleaning products,
paper products, and paint.
Now, according to the
International Organization
for Standardization, which
is also known as ISO,
these type of lifecycle
multi-attribute GEN member
labels are referred to
as type one ecolabels.
And a type one ecolabel,
as defined by ISO,
is a voluntary, multiple
criteria-based, third party
certification that identifies
environmentally preferable
products when compared to other
products of the same type using
a lifecycle basis.
Got it?
Pretty straightforward there.
So in contrast to vague, green
symbols that a lot of products
have on their labels these days
or logos that manufacturers
create for their own
products and put on
as part of their
marketing, these labels
are only found on
products that have
met these rigorous
environmental standards
and proved that they meet them
through this unbiased third
party.
Now if you shop
anytime recently,
you know there are
hundreds of green labels
that you will see
on retail products,
but also on hotels,
on restaurants,
and cleaning services.
The Ecolabel Index,
which is a website that
lists ecolabels that are
out in the marketplace,
currently lists 463
different ecolabels
in over 200 countries.
Having so many
logos and seals is
part of why we're here today.
Because it makes it
very difficult to know
which ecolabels you can trust.
So what makes the ISO type one
Global Ecolabelling Network
members different?
And that's what we're going to
talk a little bit about today
to give you some
tools to help you sort
through the hundreds
that are out there.
Because there certainly are
not hundreds of good ones.
So here are some
of the highlights.
The first one is
the certification
has to be based on a standard.
We all remember
standardized testing
from our high school days.
Everybody takes the same test.
Everybody gets a uniform score.
Colleges and universities
can know SAT score
from one person to the
next, it's comparable.
So the same thing when it comes
to environmental standards.
It's a detailed
list of requirements
that the product or service
has to meet in order to receive
that third party certification.
This is important
because the manufacturer
needs to know exactly what
their product has to do
to get that seal of approval.
But also from a consumer
standpoint or a purchaser
standpoint, if you see
that ecolabel on a product,
you need to be able to find
out exactly what that product
or service had to do to
get that seal of approval.
So there has to be a standard.
Now, developing the standard has
to be an open and transparent
process.
It has to be inclusive,
so that the public is
welcome to give input as
you go through the process.
Anyone who has a care or
information about that product
should be invited
to participate.
So this can be the
manufacturers of the product.
It can be government agencies
who regulate the product.
It can be consumer
advocacy organizations.
It can be academia that have
done studies or research.
There's a lot of
universities that
specialize in one type
of product or another.
Public health organizations.
Consumer organizations.
Anybody that has a
stake in that product
should be invited
to be a stakeholder.
And if you haven't
ever gone through
a public standard development
process, it's a very fun thing.
It makes for excellent bedtime
reading-- all the background
documents, things like that.
If you're having
trouble sleeping,
I highly recommend
standard development.
But this standard,
as you're developing,
it has to address key
environmental impacts.
And what that means is it has
to address significant impacts
over the lifecycle
of the product.
If you're looking at the
lifecycle of the product
and only addressing things
sort of on the outer edge
or the fringe, it's not
really a meaningful standard
that's going to affect some
change in the marketplace.
And so this
lifecycle perspective
is everything from
the raw material
extraction-- the mining, the
harvesting of raw materials--
how the product is manufactured.
How is it packaged?
How do you use it?
How do you service
or maintain it?
And then at the end of
its life, how do you
recycle it or safely
or effectively
dispose of it in some way?
So anything that is within that
lifecycle that's a key impact
should be included in that
environmental standard.
And if you just focus on one--
like recycled content,
which is a frequent one
that you may see--
you may be missing
other impacts that
have bigger human health
or environmental issues
in the marketplace.
But manufacturers are
certainly happy to sort of tout
the one good green thing
about their product.
But when you start asking
lifecycle questions,
it often becomes a very
quiet conversation.
So when you want to know
that somebody is actually
looking at all of
these lifecycle impacts
of the products and
services that you're buying,
and once you start thinking
about these things,
it's almost impossible
to turn it off.
As my kids and
wife will tell you,
it takes a lot longer
to shop with dad
because I look at things
a little bit differently.
So the standard also has
to consider the functional
performance of products.
And this is important because
so many green products
over the years have
been introduced
that did not work as well.
And people bought them.
And they tried them.
And they were frustrated.
And they sort of wrote off
the whole idea of we're
going to buy green products.
So we want to continue to try to
bust that myth that if you want
to be a conscientious
consumer, you
have to sacrifice performance.
Because that's
just not the case.
Now, just like any
other purchasing,
you may have to try two
or three brands that
meet your softness preference
or your color preference
or the availability in
your local marketplace.
But it's not just
because it's green
that it's not going to work.
And if you have to
use more of a product
or if you're
dissatisfied and you
throw half the product away,
that's not very sustainable.
And as I said before, if you
buy something and your laundry
doesn't get clean, or you have
to put seven coats of paint
on the wall-- and it
was a green product--
you're going to
be pretty grumpy.
And you're going to
tell lots of friends.
So we're still trying
to get past that hurdle.
Ecolabelled products have to
meet functional performance
requirements that
they work as well
as their conventional or
non-green counterparts.
Otherwise, they're
not really an option
for most purchasers
and consumers.
Now the standard also has
to be publicly available
so that you can find
out, as we said before,
what that product had to do
to get that certification.
The label is really meaningless
if you can't find out
what the criteria were in order
to get that certification.
This is one of the first
clues when you start diving
into the world of ecolabels.
If you can't find
out the criteria
upon which that
certification is based,
that usually is an indication
it may not be that robust.
And you want these standards
to be publicly available,
so that it's not a
black box with some sort
of mysterious set
of requirements.
You put a product in one
end, and out the other
and come to the certification.
Or even a gray box, because
that does call into question,
where are they
getting their funding?
How are they issuing
the certification?
Is that label really meaningful?
So the standard also needs
to be updated regularly
because the marketplace
changes from time to time.
There's new raw materials.
There's new developments.
So what's leadership
today in 2018,
two or three years from now
may not be leadership anymore.
So the standards have to be
updated on a regular basis
to keep up with recognizing
environmental leadership.
Earning the ecolabel
also has to be voluntary.
We have sort of a good
baseline regulatory framework
out there for every product
has to meet in order to be sold
legally in the marketplace.
But this is about
environmental leadership--
going above and beyond
just minimum compliance
with regulations.
And so this is part of how
companies can demonstrate
their leadership by
achieving these third party
certifications.
But in order for
this to really make
a difference in the
marketplace, the standard
and the certification also
have to be attainable.
So if you set the standard so
high that only one product out
of thousands can meet
it, that's not really
going to move the
needle very much.
And if you set it
too low, same thing.
If everybody gets it, it
doesn't really mean much.
So you're trying to find
the sweet spot of leadership
in today's marketplace,
given the raw materials
and manufacturing that's
available to us in 2018.
And the manufacturers
when they are
looking to get
this certification,
it needs to be
affordable for them.
It can't be so high that only a
few large companies can get it.
You really want to get that
critical mass of products.
Especially when it comes
to business procurement
or institutional procurement--
where they have a minimum bid
requirement to where they
have to get multiple vendors
to solicit bids--
if there's only one company
with the certification,
that doesn't really help.
One of my former colleagues
at Green Seal used to say all
the time that one of the things
that she loved about her job
was that when she worked
with a company to go through
the process of certification--
even when they had to make
changes--
that oftentimes the
company might have been
a little frustrated doing it.
But once they did it and
had that green product
and got it launched with
the third party ecolabel,
they were very rarely
ever going to go back
to the way they
did things before.
So achieving these credible
third party certifications
actually brings about
meaningful, lasting change
in the marketplace.
Which is what these are
as voluntary market tools.
It's not a regulation.
You don't have to do it.
But we're trying to identify
those leadership products
and get more people
to buy and use them.
So lastly, the
ecolabel needs to be
awarded using independent,
third party verification.
And this is probably
the most important part.
You can have a
great standard that
was developed through an open,
public, transparent process.
It hits lots of key,
significant, environmental and
human health impacts
over the lifecycle.
But if they're not doing
verification in a credible way,
then that really means
that ecolabel doesn't
have much meaning behind it.
And so what does this
verification mean?
Well, this often looks at
things like the full product
formulation, working up
and down the supply chain
to get additional disclosures
from all material suppliers.
You may or may not be surprised
to find out how many companies
sell products where they
don't actually know everything
that goes into their product.
So obtaining those
additional disclosures
is a part of the certification.
Interpreting test
results-- if there's
performance testing required
or biodegradability testing,
making sure that those
test results meet
the criteria and the standard.
Inspecting the manufacturing
facility-- that was something
I used to love to do.
Putting on safety glasses and
hard hats and ear protection
and making sure that the
companies are actually
manufacturing what they
told you on paper that they
were manufacturing.
And that the batch
records match up.
And that they bought the right
quantities of raw materials
to make the right quantities
of finished products.
And then reviewing
product labels
and marketing literature.
So you've looked at all of
their performance claims,
environmental claims,
human health claims.
But somehow, some way,
sometimes the marketing folks
get a little excited
and there may
be things in their
literature that were not
substantiated by the
review that you did
as part of the certification.
So making sure that there's no
unsubstantiated human health
or environmental claims
for which that company
didn't have data to support it.
Because at the end of the
day, that third ecolabel
represents trust to the
consumers relying upon that.
So for a service like a
restaurant or a hotel,
it's a lot of stuff
back of the house.
Looking at purchasing records.
Talking to staff.
Reviewing the training
that they've been through.
And utility records,
service schedules,
menus to make sure
that they're actually
serving the items that are
more sustainable food than not.
And all of this
sometimes takes weeks--
sometimes months-- but
it's important in both
the lengthy and
validating process.
Because ultimately the
ecolabel has to get it right.
Otherwise, there's
no trust behind it.
So these are the
types of things that
are hallmarks of the ecolabels
who are members of the Global
Ecolabelling Network.
And most of our
members will tell you
they love to say they do all
of the scientific research,
the inspection, and
the review for you.
So all you have to
do when shopping
is look for the ecolabel.
Who wouldn't want that?
Now, this is a similar map.
But these are the actual
logos for the member
labels of the Global
Ecolabelling Network.
And they represent some of
the most credible third party
certifications
available worldwide
for products and services.
And now you know
how to look for it,
and now you know which
ones to look for.
But GEN also has
affiliate members
who are not
ecolabels themselves,
but who are organizations who
support the important role
that credible third party
ecolabels can use in purchasing
and operations.
And Google is actually an
affiliate member of the Global
Ecolabelling Network.
So we need ecolabels
like this because people
care about their health.
They care about their kids.
They care about the planet.
But they really
want confirmation
that what they're buying is
what they think they're buying.
And this is a role that
these credible environmental
standards and
certifications can provide.
Now, when we talk about
the lifecycle of a product,
it's also nice to link that
these lifecycle criteria also
are related to these bigger
campaigns that we find
and issues of our day.
So ecolabels that consider
the lifecycle of a product
can help address climate
change, overflowing landfills
and poisoning of groundwater
from improper disposal,
the overwhelming
amount of plastic waste
that we keep hearing
more and more about,
the destruction of habitat
and natural resources.
And considering
the lifecycle, it
varies depending on
product to product.
But these are sort of the major
buckets that the lifecycle look
always includes.
So when we talk about
reducing the extraction
and use of fossil
fuels, some of that
is pretty obvious when you
think about the products'
manufacturing.
That you're mining
raw materials.
You're transporting
those raw materials.
There's some sort of chemical
or mechanical process
in making the product.
There's packaging that
takes energy to create,
transportation to get
that packaging to market
with the product in it, and
then ultimately the product use.
And sometimes for things
like laundry detergent,
it's actually use
at the consumer end
that has way more impact
than the manufacturing
of the product.
So you've seen a
lot of campaigns
recently about washing
with cold water detergents.
And that's because
the temperature
of your wash water--
that energy and energy
required to heat the water--
is one of the biggest impacts.
Not so much creating the
bottle of laundry detergent.
So GEN members collectively
have saved tons of fossil fuels
from being burned through
the criteria in many
of those product standards.
Now The Blue Angel,
specifically in Germany,
certifies all sorts of air
conditioning equipment.
The Eco Mark in Japan and
Nordic Swan certify biofuels.
And Good Environmental
Choice in Sweden
certifies green electricity.
So there are lots of
options for looking
for certification specific to
carbon emissions and carbon
footprint.
But it's embodied or included
in a lot of the products
standards.
It also means looking and
avoiding toxic chemicals.
19 of the 27 GEN
ecolabels currently
have standards for
cleaning products--
one of my favorite categories.
Probably my kryptonite.
I could talk about cleaning
products on and on and on--
but they have standards that
certify green cleaning products
and those standards
include restrictions
on things like carcinogens
and reproductive toxins
and asthmagens, which is a
growing thing for schools
and universities.
Green Seal in the
US also requires
that their cleaning
products be concentrated,
so that you're
not shipping water
all over the country with the
additional plastic bottles
when those concentrated
cleaners can be diluted on-site
where they're actually
going to be used.
And that reduces the
transportation impacts
and packaging as well.
When you consider the lifecycle,
it can mean reusing materials.
So the Nordic Swan
ecolabel has a standard
for remanufactured
toner cartridges.
And there's more than
12,000 different models
of toner from 13 different
manufacturers last year that
have the Nordic Swan ecolabel.
There's probably some
in your printers today.
Considering lifecycle
can also mean
reducing waste from packaging.
Ecolabelled products
and services
prevented tons of
plastic packaging
from going to the landfill.
Now, single use
plastics, when you
talk about hotels
and restaurants,
that's one of the areas that
are a part of the criteria.
And it also looks
at how the packaging
is done for the actual products
themselves-- to be minimized,
to contain recycled
content, to be
recyclable or compostable at
the end of that product's life.
So while they're not
packaging-specific,
every product standard
has some criteria
to speak to the packaging
and the impacts.
And especially with
plastic packaging
being such a hot
button today, that
could mean less plastic
ending up in our oceans,
which we keep seeing lots
and lots of commercials.
Forests is another area.
Ecosystems in forests, the old
growth habitats, the life cycle
means protecting these areas.
The China environmental
labelling program prevented
thousands of tons of new paper
pulp in 2017 by the criteria
in their paper standards.
So whether the paper is
in packaging materials,
whether it's in paper
towels and tissue products,
whether it's in copy paper, all
of these GEN member standards
for paper products have
a lot of requirements
that speak to virgin fiber.
If it's going to be used,
where it must come from.
And preferring recycled
fiber in many cases
because there are fewer impacts
coming from that fiber source.
So if you think
about all the paper
that you come into
contact with every day,
there are many, many, many
opportunities to first, reduce
that amount of paper--
refuse the receipts and paper
statements from your bank.
But when you do have to
buy paper products, looking
for ones that have
a credible ecolabel
is one way to
reduce the impacts.
Now, GEN ecolabels are also
relevant to the circular
economy-- something important
here at Google and lots
of other folks--
to businesses that are
focused on green building
as a corporate social
responsibility.
So every wall that
has paint on it--
paint is something
that's found in almost
every type of facility.
Many GEN members have
standards for virgin paint
and for recycled paint.
Because no matter how hard you
try, when you're done painting
there's always a
little bit left over.
Sometimes a lot left over.
And having that used latex
paint sort of hanging around
isn't necessarily the
best use for that.
So using leftover
paint to make new paint
and then having a
credible certification
can help people feel
better about buying
remanufactured paint
that actually performs.
And they're not suspicious
that it contains
lots of strange things.
So it can help to
close that loop.
Even though many of the products
in the marketplace today
are still very linear--
from raw materials to disposal--
the criteria in a lot
of these GEN standards--
by looking at packaging and
end of life and recyclability
or reuse--
are encouraging our steps
toward a more circular economy.
And, of course, we're
very happy to see
many, many green building rating
systems include GEN member
ecolabels as criteria
for products and services
being used within
the green buildings.
So how do you, as a consumer,
find these ecolabels
when there's lots and
lots and lots of websites
that claim to be--
here's a list of the
best ones to look for.
But a lot of those, like
everything else, are marketing.
And so when you're
shopping, first just
start paying attention
to ecolabels.
This is one of my
favorite things to do.
Look at the products, look at
the labels that are on there,
and then start to think
about some questions that you
can ask or check and look up.
Is it an actual certification?
Or is it just a logo
created by the manufacturer?
If it is an actual
certification,
can you find the standard?
Do you know why that
product was awarded that?
If you can find the standard,
how was the verification
that it met the standard done?
Is it just the company claiming
we claim we meet the standard?
Or is it done by an
actual third party?
Once you start thinking
about these sort
of few fundamental questions
when you see those labels,
you'll get a good
feel for whether they
tend to be on the credible side
or the not so credible side.
So, yes, we're asking to do
a little bit of homework.
But because you vote
with your wallet
and you're sending that message
every time you make a purchase,
it is really important.
And you can send that message
to your favorite products
and services, as well.
If they don't carry one of
these ecolabels already,
you can ask them, could
you get this certification?
Would you consider posting
it on social media?
There's been a lot of good
ways to get response--
not just from your
cable company--
to companies responding to
why they don't have that.
It is something that you as
a consumer do have a voice
and can ask more of.
You also have a lot of
influence about what others buy.
And this was one of my
favorite areas of opportunity.
So most of us may
recycle and practice
sustainability at home,
places like Google,
definitely at work.
But you're not home now.
And because we spend
a third or more
of our days outside
of the home, you
can really think about
asking some key questions
of the places that you visit.
So I know my kids and your kids
may be at daycare or school
right now.
You'll go to the
gym later or maybe
you already went this morning.
You might go out to a
restaurant for dinner.
Maybe take a trip this
weekend and stay at a hotel.
So when you are at
these places, feel
free to ask what are they
doing about sustainability
and what green
products do they buy.
Now, my colleagues
will tell you I
am notorious for taking pictures
when I see signs advertising,
"We proudly use green products."
I look under the sink
in the restrooms,
and I look for
ecolabel on the bottle
of hand soap in the restroom.
The roll of toilet
paper often has
a label with an ecolabel on it.
So if you start to look for
these things, like I said,
it's hard to turn it off.
But you can make a difference.
If you don't see it,
you can ask questions.
Hey, have you ever thought
about purchasing green products?
Or tell me more about
this product that you buy.
There are some
greener alternatives.
Especially if you
come from a place
where that's just
standard business practice
in your day to day life.
So tell them that you want
them to use green products
and check back with
them periodically.
Because they may need
continued nudging.
A personal example of this is
my CrossFit gym back at home.
In the restrooms they have
little tiny 99 cent bottles
of liquid hand soap they
were buying at the drugstore,
which, of course, they
kept trying to refill.
They didn't last very
long because there's
lots of chalk dust
and perspiration
to wash off after workouts.
So I finally-- after
a few conversations,
which they probably thought
were a little strange at first--
got them to switch over
to a bulk hand soap
dispenser with foam
soap, which actually
has 1,400 uses worth of
soap in it versus 100 or 200
in the little bottle.
Because foam soap comes
out pretty lathered,
it actually takes less
time to wash your hands.
It takes less time to rinse
the soap off your hands.
So there's less packaging.
They're saving energy.
They're saving water.
And they don't have
to change out the soap
and refill it as often.
So, small victory at home.
Every time I go in
CrossFit, wash my hands,
I look at that little label
and I know I did a good thing.
So we have that same
opportunity in the places
that we patronize.
To start asking
these questions, they
may think you're a
little odd at first.
But they'll get over it.
And the more
ecolabelled products
you buy, the more times you're
asking for these things,
the more we're going to see
them in the marketplace.
And that's a good thing.
So meanwhile, we're
going to be celebrating
on the 25th of October with
events around the globe.
GEN members are getting out,
educating manufacturers,
consumers, retailers in
their own country and region.
And I'd like to play for
you just a couple of clips
from longer videos that some
of the GEN members have done.
So we're going to see some
promotions from Environmental
Choice New Zealand, the
Vitality Leaf in Russia,
the Singapore green label,
and the Thailand green label.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- World Ecolabel Day is
coming up this October.
It's the day when we focus
on products and services that
carry ecolabels, badges that
say the products or services are
environmentally preferable.
[END PLAYBACK]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[END PLAYBACK]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- In Singapore,
we label something
like 3,700 products using
the Ecolabelling Network.
And the products actually
enter 43 countries today.
[END PLAYBACK]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Do you know the
environmentally friendly
products?
- Yes.
The environmentally
friendly products
is basically a product that
doesn't destroy nature,
like recycling.
- Do you know certified
Green Label products?
- Yes.
The certified
Green Label product
is a product that has
received a Green Label
for not destroying nature.
- To celebrate the
World Ecolabelling Day,
use environmentally
friendly products.
Don't forget Green Label.
Hurray!
MARK PETRUZZI: All right.
And now, so here
are three reasons
why I spend so much time
shopping for green products
and looking at the products
that we eat and use
and put on our bodies.
And, of course, they're
sports and they're
used to this by now.
But when we are shopping, I take
the time to explain to my kids
why we're buying this
product over that product.
And explaining, usually
it's something like,
well, one has ingredients that
Daddy doesn't really like.
But they're pretty good with it.
And I also point out-- now,
obviously the one of them
looking at product
labels, that one--
we're not quite there yet.
But we're working toward that.
And just educating
them to be consumers
that think about these things.
Hopefully some of it
is going to stick.
And it's certainly
easier if I can just
tell them when they're shopping
look for this logo on products.
And in fact, for
many years, they're,
Daddy, your logo's
on this product.
In fact, one of my
favorite examples
is the Subway chain
of restaurants.
In all 25,000 Subways
in North America
has a Green Seal certified
hand soap in their restrooms
and behind the sink for
the sandwich artists
to wash their hands.
So we come from
a sporting event,
we hit Subway to get a
healthier sandwich for dinner,
and the kids all go in the
bathroom to wash their hands
and they see the Green
Seal on the little window
in the soap dispenser.
And it warms my heart.
So finding that once you
get them trained to start
looking for it, it is possible.
And, of course, for my daughter,
for every serious picture
we take she has to take one
that's a not serious picture.
So that's her go to
not serious face.
So at some point we hopefully
won't need as many regulations
about the safety of products.
We hopefully won't
need as many ecolabels
to guide people towards safer,
greener, healthier products.
And GEN members might
all be out of a job.
But that's OK.
But just in time for
World Ecolabel Day,
you now know a little bit more
of how to look behind the label
and find out what
green really means.
But if you want
to find out more,
certainly visit
GlobalEcolabelling.net.
Check out the ideas and tools
for celebrating World Ecolabel
Day at WorldEcolabelDay.com.
And we hope you'll be inspired
to be a little bit more
of a green product
sleuth and help us create
a more sustainable world.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I'm curious about
the third party certifiers.
Is there an audit process to
see that they're keeping up
standard as to doing the process
of reviewing a product that
meets the standards.
MARK PETRUZZI: Yes.
There are-- what we in
the certification world
call-- standards for
standards and standards
for standard developers and
standards for certifiers.
So earlier Richard
mentioned in my bio,
one of the things
that happened recently
was the United States
Environmental Protection Agency
led an effort that
came up with 67 draft
guidelines for credible third
party standards and ecolabels.
And those guidelines were
divided into four sections.
So any label that the
federal government
was considering using would have
to meet these 67 guidelines.
So the first section was how
you develop your standards.
That's a pretty key one.
And there are a number
of other standards
that sort of were embodied
in their questions.
Then there was a section on
how do you do your verification
and conformity assessment.
In some programs the label
who developed the standard
does the certification.
In some, there are programs
who just develop the standard
and then other third parties
can do the verification work
provided they meet accreditation
as the certifying body.
Then the third section was the
credibility of the program.
Where did they
get their funding?
Who's on their
board of directors?
Are there any
conflicts of interest
in operating the program?
And then the fourth section,
which is potentially
the most interesting,
are the standards
environmentally effective?
That is, if you buy something
with that ecolabel on it,
are you actually getting
the benefits that they
say you're going to get?
So that speaks to addressing the
key, significant environmental
impacts and making
sure that it's not
a label that is sort of
dancing around the edges
but not hitting to the
heart of the matter.
So yes, there are standards
and accreditations
that standard developers
and third party
certifiers have to meet.
And these are embodied in
membership requirements
for the Global
Ecolabelling Network.
In order to join,
you have to prove
that you meet all of those.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
about forestry certifications.
So you mentioned it, but just
to make sure I caught it.
So for like FSC certified wood,
is that part of the Global
Ecolabelling Network.
Why or why not?
Or other forestry
certifications.
MARK PETRUZZI: Right.
Great question.
Thank you.
The GEN member
ecolabels tend to be
for programs that cover multiple
types of products and services.
And within the
forestry space, there
are six, eight or
so labels that just
certify sustainable
forestry in some way,
shape, or form whether that's
virgin or post-consumer.
Some of them actually do put
a certification on products.
But none of them,
to my knowledge,
would be able to be a member of
the Global Ecolabelling Network
because they only
focus on forestry.
And just like there are labels
that just focus on indoor air
quality or just focus
on sustainable flooring,
in order to be a
GEN member, you have
to have standards for multiple
product and service categories.
But it is also a really
relevant question,
because these same
questions about how do they
develop their standards?
How do they do their
conformity assessment?
Are they addressing the
key impacts of forestry
within that space of
six or eight labels?
Some are better than
others, and that's
been the topic of much debate
in the green building community.
So, yes.
And the nice thing about these
key fundamental principles
is they can apply to
a single attribute
program, a multiple criteria but
applying to a single category
program, or a type
one ecolabel that
addresses life cycle across
multiple product categories.
So that's planting
the seeds of these
are the questions to
be thinking about when
you look behind that
label wherever it fits.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about furniture.
I haven't seen a lot of
ecolabels or see any.
Maybe I didn't pay
attention enough.
Can you tell me more
about the furniture?
Is there an ecolabel for the
office furniture or any type
of furniture products?
MARK PETRUZZI: Yes.
There are a few.
Many furniture products have
gone through indoor air quality
certification for emissions,
where the chair or the table
is put into a chamber.
The chamber is closed,
and they actually
measure what is offgassed in
terms of multiple compounds.
Greenguard is probably the
most well-known for that.
But there is also--
for institutional furniture--
the Business and Institutional
Furniture Manufacturers
Association--
BIFMA-- has a
program called Level
that is for institutional
office furniture.
And they have
hundreds of products
that have been certified
at three different levels
in the Level rating system.
But there are some
certifications.
But most of it is
for institutional
and office furniture.
There is the Sustainable
Furnishings Association
for retail furniture that
has some of the furniture
companies as members.
But that hasn't been as visible
as the BIFMA Level program.
But yes, it's a growing
area of concern.
And also that's a market where--
in addition to the emissions
from the foam cushions--
things like flame retardants
and brominated compounds
have been sort of a
campaign-specific thing
because these products are
used in schools and offices.
And we're exposed to them
a lot of hours of the day.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned funding.
And I'd be really concerned
if the people getting
the certifications paid for it.
But at the same
time, I know there's
no way that I could pay for it.
So what's the current thinking
around seemingly hard to solve
problem?
MARK PETRUZZI: Some
of the GEN members
are government-sponsored
programs.
So there is some endowment
and funding coming from that.
Some of them do take
a fee for service
where there is a fee for
getting the certification.
And this is why the question
about the accreditation for how
they operate is so important.
Usually it's a fee-- the same
fee charged to everybody--
initially.
And then there may
be a license fee
that's based on the
sales of the product.
So if you sold 100 products,
at the end of that term of 12
months or whatever
the term was, you
would owe a fee for the use
of the Ecolabel on that.
So unfortunately,
fees are definitely
a part of it to keep the
organization running.
But then for a lot of
the nonprofit labels--
because of the 501(c)(3)
IRS tax classification--
they're not allowed to have any
direct financial relationship.
So they may just charge
a flat fee and that's
irrespective of how
many units actually
get sold in the marketplace.
So whether the company sells
one or they sell one million,
the fee is an evaluation fee
to determine whether or not
you meet the standard and
get the certification.
But it's not directly linked
to the success of that product
in the marketplace.
So there are a variety of
different funding models.
and it is a challenge because
the marketplace really
needs to show the value for
this in the business case.
And the business case
is often the companies
see that marketing benefit
of having the third party
certification.
So paying for it helps
to keep the lights on
and the doors open
for the ecolabel.
AUDIENCE: So there
was a slide where
you showed all different
ecolabels, not all of them
part of GEN. As a
consumer, most consumers
aren't super knowledgeable
of what ecolabels
are part of GEN.
Is there a trend
that it's going to become
more easy for consumers
to know what valid
ecolabels are or how--
Because most consumers
wouldn't spend time
to research all the
different ecolabels
before going to the store.
Right?
MARK PETRUZZI: Right.
And that's a great question.
And that's part of why
this education campaign
and having the first annual
World Ecolabel Day is something
that GEN thought of.
Because yes, even people like me
that have been immersed in this
don't study all
463 on the website.
But I've got the tools if I see
something at the grocery store
that I haven't seen
before, I'll whip out
my phone I'll start looking.
OK.
What is this green tree logo
that I've never seen before?
And usually within a few
clicks on that mobile website
I can-- oh, at
the bottom it says
funded by the such and
such industry association.
Or I can see that
we at Company X
think this is our company
environmental program.
We put this on all our
products to show our commitment
to the environment.
So you can tease
out pretty quickly
if it's a credible label
or not, but it is going
to take a little bit of work.
And without somebody coming in
and policing the marketplace,
the EPA effort to identify
the good ones for use
in federal procurement,
Google's efforts
by being an affiliate member of
GEN to say, hey, as a company,
we only want to
use ecolabels that
meet our strict guidelines.
That sends a signal.
But it also, for the
time being, requires
consumers taking a
little bit of effort
to determine whether or
not that smells fishy.
AUDIENCE: And do you all have
an app or anything like that?
MARK PETRUZZI: No.
I don't think the
Global Ecolabelling
Network has an app yet.
That's probably on their
wish list for funding.
AUDIENCE: Just curious
about your knowledge
of the prevalence
of fraud with some
of these certified products.
I was working on
a startup before.
We were looking into
organic agriculture fraud.
There have been large scandals
with some products people tried
to pass off as
certified organic.
But curious about
the other products,
as well, how prevalent that is.
MARK PETRUZZI: It is a problem.
And that's one of
the 67 guidelines
that I mentioned that
EPA had put forth--
and even in the ISO standard
and the GEN requirements--
policing and enforcing your
ecolabel is super important.
And all the time I
spend at Green Seal,
a big portion of that
was spent on enforcement.
And having the products that
are Green Seal certified listed
on our website was the
first step in that.
Because consumers, especially
the institutional purchasers--
a company would come
in and make a pitch.
We'd like you to
buy our product.
We're Green Seal
certified-- they would
verify that on our website.
And if it wasn't on our website,
we would get a phone call.
Hey, Company X was
just in my office.
They said they were certified.
I can't find them
on your website.
Now sometimes they
were just super excited
we hadn't posted it
on the website yet.
So they were
legitimately certified.
But maybe they were
but two years ago.
And we terminated
their certification,
but they had an old
paper with the old logo
or something on it.
So yes, there are
requirements that the mark has
to be legally protected,
registered as a certification
mark, that you do have to take
steps to police and enforce it.
Usually that hierarchy
would be something
like they would get
a phone call from me.
If that didn't work, they would
get a phone call or a letter
from our CEO.
If that didn't work, then
they would get a lovely letter
from a four name
law firm saying,
you are using a registered
certification mark
without license.
Cease and desist or else.
And sometimes it came to that.
We would even police and enforce
registration of domain names.
Because a manufacturer having
Green Seal dot whatever,
that wasn't actually Green
Seal, but was somehow
promoting their products
or leading people
to think under that
pretense that they were.
That's a misuse of
our name and mark.
So yes, it's a
never-ending battle.
Yes, some of them are
going to slip through.
But every time I read one
of those I'm like you.
I think, oh, that's not great.
But it's great that
it comes to light
so they can hopefully implement
better controls over it.
And it speaks to the value that
companies want to misuse it
because they know they will
be able to sell more or reach
a target audience that--
if they don't have it--
they may not be able to sell to.
So it shows that
there's a value for it.
But yes, eternal
vigilance is the price
of ecolabelling I guess.
SPEAKER: Thank you, again, Mark.
And thank you everyone
for your questions.
We really appreciate your time.
So let give it up for Mark.
MARK PETRUZZI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]